je ne sais pas si tu fais moi une démo
unijob je pense à la bombe et des
missions madame alors vous êtes
vétérinaire oui
fargues vernir vétérinaire mais c'est
bien la clinique bonjour excusez moi de
vous déranger c'est cyril hanouna
non mais ça va très bien alors je vous
appelle j'ai un problème j'ai mal à une
patte avec eva ne s est pas l'autre je
fais non alors on a je voulais vous
offrir vous appeler comme en quelques
minutes comment ça lui stéphanie elle
habite où celle ci
j'adore je suis à deux barrages pas ce
soir je vais accrocher paru il s'est
fait bien club de tennis à bas la sat
agneray via d'ordre j'ai servi d'appât
alors c'est fanny vous êtes donc on fait
quoi vous êtes la fermière vétérinaire
déjà bravo pour tout ce que vous faites
il ya pas mal d'animaux qui me
remercient sur le plateau de dire ça
c'est nedzad deuxième chose stéphanie
est ce que vous êtes finances et marié
en concubinage avec des enfants avec des
amis avec des potes j'ai des potes et
pottas la compote célibataire oui
c'était facile
je vous le dis je vais vous offrir deux
places même jeu mais quatre places pour
aller voir le film veto avec clovis
cornillac cool ou pas les vétos mais
c'est les vetos et pour moi c'est
qu'elle remet arrêté ne mettez pas de
musique ont offert mon plan rona h
[Applaudissements]
quand on me demande d'être heureux
cadeaux jeux boites téléphonie c'était
prenez vous aimez les animaux
ah oui vraiment la wii a bien entendu
vous les aimez les voyages les voyages
voyages à thoiry je vous envoie et dans
un safari en ile de france
pour moi c'est cadeau à sa part on
verrait si ces fonds à des éléphants ça
c'est le foot locker on mettra les tirs
oulala supermarché au monoprix frostis
de kellogg's stéphanie mack série est-ce
que c'est parfait je vais te faire un à
ses jours je t'embrasse et t'aime bien
londres non bah oui je t'envoie ibiza
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour moi c'est cadeau du parrain
tu vas partir tu abordes tu t'inquiètes
pas là j'appelle une compagnie aérienne
qui existent cependant avoir une face
aux tchèques n pas je te fout ça tu vas
partir en séjours en duo partout en
france partout partout partout pas
arrêté je peux faire un voyage à
l'étranger est content que stéphanie
super content tu vas partir avec qui je
suis pas encore si tu veux la bernard
montiel calibre toi on sait se
trouverait bien quelqu'un
[Applaudissements]
vous aimez la crise cardiaque
bah oui on l'a d'or no 6 un très grand
acteur est allé voir le film les vétos
ça c'est pour moi donc il ya les quatre
passes pour les métaux le séjour en
france et je vous offre également un
guépard voilà c'est pas moi c'est cadeau
voilà ma chérie je t'embrasse porter
famille tu te remercie beaucoup
[Applaudissements]